and went welcome to this video play our
penguin so not not good the last couple
of games maybe I can end the streak with
a bank oh well cut this line I have not
gotten I think in in one of the games
yet ok so a three is the more frequently
played move here who should be 3m
sometimes this a 3 a 3 is still probably
in yeah somehow part of this position ok
so he tries to do some Bishop a 5 and so
on here right this is the prom this is
the idea let's see you
yeah maybe he's slightly better here I
don't know with the aprons possible a
porn is fairly fairly dangerous him I
don't think it should be terrible for me
but ok so it's very confident here if I
take here Queen takes I don't win the
pawn 98 looks kind of normal
maybe not be six is strong just just
trying to get the pawn to d6 it might be
it might be yeah maybe not be six the
bishop is unprotected but I I don't see
a tactic here no I don't know was that
the most dangerous route takes bah
yes but this also also I mean here's
less protection now right let's
protection of this porn currently it is
not like running quickly I mean
definitely not
if I take everything I let the end up
Lacey form yeah I know it's let this set
is that good or not I can also play
Queen to b4 here's an interesting move
495 well it's interesting let's try that
and you never know here's Queenie one
meet very unlikely to happen but you can
always always hope if it takes it night
sir five will definitely be okay for me
coming I mean 95 and then attack the
porn by a night be seven or 93 okay i'm
not i'm not getting the checkmate not
getting the checkmated this one and
that's probably not bad let's think for
a moment no okay this one what's going
on here I don't I don't get to win the
porn I can approach it with the King
maybe tonight is keeping things somewhat
under control I wonder if six is doing
anything it just goes back okay
93 maybe the idea if i go to be three
here is going 94 i guess i don't know
you have to be able to cook a ham check
I just want to go to be fine and pick it
up if possible
did I have 9 p-3 check check check check
check check now here's a yes a couple of
chicks here as well yeah cut captain
Kayla that save some time marginally
ha probably have to draw off her young
draw is there a repetition yeah maybe it
could have picked it up one room earlier
like here cooperative play dead right I
know talking to double check ah ok ok ok
ok so this was this was correct then ha
ha ha sorry back and then I couldn't do
much there hmm ok so let's fire up the
engine you cap yeah this is a normal
theoretical position right normally I
mean the move the main move is a 3 here
and then I know that is 6 is correct and
then I kind of forgot everything this
one day I can still play six maybe I
should yeah it really felt like I was in
danger here this felt like I'm in danger
now that the airport is a dangerous
dangerous asset here for white yeah yeah
i think this helped me a bit to somehow
the ship's III seemed to help me Knight
b6 and I'm gonna take it Bishop takes
hmm he's better with the airport I
probably should have played early
insects I mean here i think i'm mostly
out of the woods oakland 87 was good and
I didn't see that ok now I'm threatening
to take NJ know what do I threaten
actually ok right do a new friend to
take on c4 I know
if 50 and the problem is like this yeah
FC phone yeah I'm willing upon reading
the apron okay but that was a more than
coincidental thing I mean here I think
the likelihood of a draw is pretty high
cap ha ha ha got to be a draw at the end
I didn't not really find this is a nummy
you draw this seems to be a bit more
testing it's immensely trickier in a low
time situation with all the nights but
then very likely it's also some kind of
troll ok guys thanks for watching